you do not see
the real world
your eyes
are lying to you
or more precisely
your brain
in 2011 scientists at new york
university ran a study which showed that
we may perceive threatening objects to
be closer than they really are
in january this year researchers at the
university of california found that in
an effort to create a continuous image
our vision is stuck up to 15 seconds in
the past as do youtube videos so our
brains need time to buffer
and finally
the sun
is green
at a young age we learn we mustn't ever
look directly upon it but those that
dare perhaps to witness the fleeting
beauty of a sunrise gaze upon a warm
yellow orb that gives life to most
species on earth this colour is not a
trick of the eye but a trick of the air
molecules of nitrogen and oxygen scatter
blue light away from us more making the
sun look redder than it truly is
but escape the bounds of the atmosphere
and to the human eye the sun would
appear the purest white a combination of
every wavelength of colour it emits in
different quantities
and this is the lie the colour white
created in our minds
objectively the sun is of all colors
green emitting more green photons than
any other wavelength
[Music]
and that is not the only way our eyes
deceive us in regards to our closest
star
ultraviolet rays that tan our skin
infrared that warms our faces when we
step out on a sunny morning radio waves
which can be picked up by our technology
our sun is constantly producing massive
amounts of photons that stream around
and through us at wavelengths our eyes
simply did not evolve to perceive
these limitations mean we bathe in a
constant wash of particles that we
simply cannot see
and this hidden world is not only made
up
of light the sun also produces massive
waves of particles that are so
unresponsive as to have been completely
undetected or even conceived of until
the 20th century and yet are so numerous
that across the universe they outnumber
the particles that make up ordinary
matter
a billion to one
it is with these neutrinos we may be
able to answer some of the deepest
questions about our cosmos
the oldest light in the universe the
cosmic microwave background is 380 000
years younger than the big bang itself
before that the universe was too hot and
too dense for light to travel freely but
if the oldest images of the cosmos are
still 380 thousand years old how could
we ever know what happened
before
what if we want to know what the
universe was like not just in its first
year
but its first
second
our telescopes cannot tell us they have
reached an opaque barrier they cannot
penetrate
yet astronomers have found a way to pull
back
the veil
to uncover these early moments in time
pushing back the clock to the most
ancient map of the cosmos there is
but to do that they will first have to
probe the secrets of these cosmic ghosts
secrets that challenge our very
understanding of how the universe
works
this video has been kindly sponsored by
better help many scientists believe the
universe is infinite and that can get
lonely sometimes better help is an easy
to use platform that helps you access
therapy from your phone or computer the
last couple of years have been difficult
for everyone and it's so important to
not only stay physically healthy but
mentally too one of the barriers for me
had always been that in times of crisis
i didn't know how to find someone to
talk to so it felt easier just to ignore
it better help are a great solution to
this problem with over 20 000 therapists
with a broad range of expertise just a
click away all you need to do is access
their platform fill out the
questionnaire with your specific needs
and better help will match you with a
licensed therapist to listen and help
you it's convenient straightforward and
trusted by more than two million people
who have signed up and tried it
so head over to betterhelp that's better
help dot com forward slash hot you for
ten percent off your first month thanks
again to better help for supporting
education on youtube
why would you build a telescope
inside an airplane
it is the morning of december the 1st
2010. at the end of its 10 hour flight a
retrofitted boeing 747 returns to an air
force runway in palmdale california
one change is instantly noticeable
peering out a retractable door at the
rear of the plane rests the 20-ton 2.7
meter wide mirror of the sofia infrared
telescope
when the weather warms it flies south
for a second winter from palmdale to
christchurch new zealand the annual
migration allows access to an entirely
different part of the sky during its
observation periods as many as 100
flights a year sophia flies at an
altitude of 12 or so kilometers not all
that higher than most commercial flights
and in doing so it captures a light that
the air beneath it would block
water it not only forms clouds which
block visible lines of sight while it
looks clear to us in small quantities
entire oceans reveal its true nature it
appears blue because it absorbs red
light and it also absorbs invisible
infrared light infrared light that holds
the universe's most distant secrets as
the universe expands light stretches and
after enough time much of it arrives to
the infrared
sofia flies 99 of the planet's water is
beneath it the telescope can catch
wavelengths of light that would never
make it to other equipment on the ground
wavelengths that denote the births and
deaths of stars the formations of
planets and even dust surrounding
supermassive black holes at the heart of
galaxies
for more than a century humanity has had
to use technology to overcome the limits
of our perception
telescopes can reveal to us the massive
made insignificant through distance
microscopes magnify what is under our
very noses the smaller the object of
study the smaller a wavelength of light
you need in order to study it in detail
today electron microscopes can achieve
resolutions 4 000 times smaller than any
optical microscope
but how do you study or even detect the
smallest known particle
in the universe
a particle so small we don't actually
know how small it is
[Music]
in late 1951 frederick reigns and clyde
l cowan jr began project poltergeist the
first experiment in neutrino physics
two decades prior the physicist and
mathematician wolfgang pauli had
proposed the concept of the neutrino he
sought to balance an equation governing
the process of nuclear decay in some
unstable nuclei a neutron will
spontaneously transform into a proton
and an electron the exact amount of
energy was based on the principle of
balance add up all the energy in the
particles at the start of a reaction and
it should equal the total energy of all
the particles present at the end of it
but the electrons experiments were
catching all came up wanting either the
law of energy conservation was wrong at
this level of subatomic particles or
another source of energy was missing
perhaps as wolfgang paulie first
proposed there was an even smaller
particle which the neutron had broken up
into a particle neutral in charge which
escaped the nucleus but also escaped
capture
direct detection of these neutrinos was
deemed essentially impossible they were
simply too small and too ghostly 100
trillion of them stream through your
body every single second as if you were
simply not there
in fact paulie once said of the neutrino
i have done a terrible thing i have
postulated a particle that cannot be
detected
[Music]
but it was the nuclear revolution of the
1940s
that eventually
proved him wrong
a child of russian immigrants frederick
raines was born in a small new jersey
town in 1918. as a boy he developed a
love of music singing in particular but
his love of science grew from a moment
of boredom in school where he looked out
a window and noticed the splitting of
light known as diffraction rain's
passion eventually led to a phd in
theoretical nuclear physics and he
joined the manhattan project in 1944
over the years he rose up the ranks to
eventually head nuclear weapons testing
in the pacific
it was during a sabbatical that he
realized the nuclear fission reactions
provided by the deadliest bomb known to
humanity could provide the concentration
of neutrinos needed to detect one of
them
still he likened it to listening for a
nat's whisper in a hurricane
as the 1950s dawned project poltergeist
planned to capture the elusive particle
for the very first time by detonating a
20 kiloton nuclear payload
which could provide a surge of neutrinos
in sufficient quantity that maybe a mere
handful actually had a chance of being
picked up by a detector placed a mere 50
meters away from the
explosion this detector was filled with
a special mix of liquids that would
flash in rare circumstance the creation
of a charged particle after a neutrino
collision a thousand times larger than
previous detectors they named it
el monstro
thankfully reigns and his colleagues
realized that if they added cadmium
salts to their liquid they could make it
even more sensitive a bomb would no
longer be necessary
a nuclear reactor one could turn on
leave running and turn off became the
most sensible option and in june of 1956
reigns sent to communique to poorly
a neutrino collision had been detected
neutrinos were no longer theory a
mathematical concept used to balance the
equations of the universe's inner
workings
they were real
if barely tangible
nearly four decades later reigns was
awarded the nobel prize for his work
nowadays modern detectors make their
neutrinos a little differently the micro
boone experimented firmer lab and
upcoming dune project employ liquid
argon as a detector and fermilab creates
neutrinos using a particle accelerator
but not all detectors need to make their
own neutrinos some are on the hunt for
those crafted by nature itself
the ice cube array in antarctica
features 86 cables drilled into the ice
encompassing a total volume of one cubic
kilometer equivalent to a million
swimming pools
since opening in 2011 ice cube has
hunted for the rare neutrino which has
traversed billions of light years
for any and all of these projects the
important factor is shielding neutrino
detectors are hidden in mines underneath
hundreds if not thousands of meters of
rock or in ice cube's case
solid ice this prevents other small
particles raining down on earth from
causing interference cosmic noise that
would otherwise drown out the minuscule
signal a handful of neutrinos every so
often deign to give
but the question remains just why are
neutrinos so incredibly hard to detect
and why does that make them ideal for
detecting the earliest moments
of the cosmos
[Music]
in your entire lifetime the likelihood
of you interacting with neutrino
is about 25
not bad odds you may think
and yet 100 billion pass through your
thumbnail
every second
about 180 million billion neutrinos
produced only by our sun passed through
the earth every minute
a light year of lead would only stop
half the neutrinos passing through it
generally neutrinos simply do not
interact with other particles be they
matter or be they light
the four fundamental forces of gravity
electromagnetism and the strong and weak
nuclear forces govern how particles
interact with one another gravity draws
everything with mass together
like tiny beads rolling along
depressions of space-time created by the
presence of others the greater the mass
the deeper the depression the greater
the appearance of gravitational pull
for a long while neutrinos were thought
to have no mass whatsoever just like
photons while they could fall along the
curves in space-time they left no tracks
of their own for other similarly small
particles to notice
yet photons are the messengers of the
electromagnetic force
anything with electric charge in our
day-to-day anything that's made of
protons and electrons interacts with the
electromagnetic force to some degree but
neutrinos are the ultimate neutral
particle they are not composed of
smaller pieces and are neither
influenced by electric nor magnetic
fields tiny neutrinos simply slip
through the gaps
of course the mysterious substance
called dark matter is invisible to the
electromagnetic force but at the very
least we can see its gravitational
influence
the strongest of the forces is the
strong nuclear force which has the job
of binding together fundamental
particles called quarks and as a
byproduct holds together neutrons and
protons that make up the nucleus of an
atom
neutrinos however are not quarks and so
the strong force too is happily ignored
the only fundamental force that
neutrinos appear to be ruled by is the
weak nuclear force indeed this was the
very reason poorly predicted their
existence as the weak force needed to
create them to maintain a balance of
energy
in this way neutrinos are ghosts barely
skirting the laws that govern our
reality
[Music]
they exist to explain why the energies
of certain particles and certain
reactions that we really can measure
look the way they do but that does not
mean that they are exclusively cosmic
duct tape injected into physics merely
to make our equations look nice
we can use them as probes studying some
of the most extreme events
in the universe
on february the 23rd 1987 a 168 000 year
old explosion
struck the earth
an international effort hunted down the
culprit in the large magellanic cloud a
dwarf satellite galaxy of the milky way
the nuclear furnace of a massive star
had failed
a gravitational implosion concentrated
enough of the star's mass for one last
death whale
a supernova
but hours before the light of this
cosmic explosion had reached our
telescopes a detector inside a zinc mine
collected the signatures
of 11
neutrinos
[Music]
born in 1926 masatoshi koshiba had
originally planned on studying german
literature but after receiving a failing
grade in physics he overheard his
teacher speaking ill of his abilities
spite it turned out was a powerful
motivator
a month later he'd raised his grade
enough to pass the requirements for the
physics department
when he eventually attended new york's
university of rochester for his phd he
completed the program in less than two
years
fast forward to the 1970s and kosheba
sought to rewrite the laws of physics
he wanted to observe
the decay
of protons
he'd hoped to prove the grand unified
theory which sought to unite the two
models with which physicists describe
the universe
general relativity and quantum mechanics
and this is what his kameoka nucleon
decay experiment or camioca nde was
meant to do a cylindrical tank holding
4500 tons of water hidden a kilometer
underground
but ultimately protons proved far too
stable if they ever do break down it
happens so rarely the koshiba's machine
would never be sensitive enough to catch
one in the act
however he did realize that with a
retrofit it could be sensitive enough to
catch neutrinos streaming through the
planet
the arrangement of a thousand photo
detectors would also indicate from what
direction they were coming and just two
months after his experiment began
collecting data koshiba's team hit
the proverbial jackpot
it was actually two days after supernova
1987a's light had reached earth
researchers at the university of
pennsylvania had sent a fax to their
colleagues in tokyo informing them of
the explosion and it was here they found
what they'd been waiting for
for 13 seconds kamioka nde had captured
a burst of neutrinos streaming through
the earth
the timing had been perfect only a few
minutes prior the detector was shot down
for a full two minutes
and so kamioka nde helped open up a new
era of astronomy which hoped to unveil
natural phenomenon too opaque for light
to penetrate
[Music]
and over the last decade neutrino
detectors have been joined by
gravitational wave detectors that have
helped astronomers explore the mergers
of black holes and neutron stars
in 2017 the ligo gravitational wave
detector picked up 100 seconds of two
neutron stars spiraling down towards
each other and finally merging over 70
light-based observatories including some
high above the earth's surface pointed
their telescopes toward the event
collecting information across the
electromagnetic spectrum
and an energetic system also allows for
the creation of neutrinos
however unlike supernova 1987a all those
years ago
none of the neutrinos captured by
earth's detectors could be traced back
to this merger
while disappointing it was not expected
the event was so brief that it made
detection unlikely
however a future neutron star merger may
provide an opportunity for photon
capturing telescopes gravitational wave
detectors and neutrino detectors to work
in tandem providing three different
images of the same object
thus marking the beginning of the era of
multi-messenger astronomy
slowly but surely the previously
untouchable neutrino is joining the
ranks of particles used to study objects
throughout the universe
and some scientists believe we can even
use these invisible particles to unveil
something even more distant
[Music]
the beginning of the universe itself
[Music]
this is the cosmic microwave
background
our universe's
baby picture
the photons captured in this image
describe the entire state of the visible
cosmos a mere 380 000 years after the
big bang
at this moment the universe changed from
being opaque to transparent
over the subsequent 13.7 billion or so
years these photons have touched every
corner of the universe in a 45.6
billion light-year radius and in their
travels their wavelengths have stretched
out longer and longer
today we can only detect them with radio
telescopes indeed they were first
detected as a form of static coming from
every possible direction in the sky
by studying the cosmic microwave
background otherwise known as the cmb
astronomers can turn back the clock to
that 380 thousand year age but with
light
we can go
no further
to peer beyond the cmb astronomers must
rely on a different particle
one which freed itself long before the
photon did
they need to capture an image of the c
newbie
the cosmic neutrino background
as the very first second entered the
annals of history the universe had
already experienced quite the cosmic
ordeal
it had gone through inflation
distinguished the four fundamental
forces and quarks had either combined to
form composite particles like protons
and neutrons or annihilated with
antimatter twins
neutrinos and anti-neutrinos were just
part of the hot cosmic soup
thrashing around colliding with other
particles including photons they were
not the ghosts we know of today it was
simply too hot
neutrinos were effectively coupled to
everything else
scattering with each collision rather
than passing through mata as if nothing
was there at all
but space was ever expanding the density
of particles in each minute portion of
three-dimensional space ever dropping
the time between collisions was getting
longer particles themselves were slowing
down and decreasing in energy and that
decrease corresponded to a drop in
temperature
at one second old temperatures had
reached an order of 10 billion degrees
celsius a temperature completely
incomprehensible to us a temperature a
thousand times more intense than what's
found at the core of our sun
but
finally particles were zipping around
just slowly enough
for neutrinos
to break free
[Music]
they no longer crashed into quarks or
electrons or even light itself
the universe was still opaque at all
wavelengths of light as it would remain
for hundreds of thousands of years but
for neutrinos all had been made clear
and this cosmic neutrino background
where scientists able to image it would
reveal the state of the universe at this
very moment
the universe at one
second old
[Music]
in the intervening years these relic
neutrinos have continued to lose energy
but they are still out there
everywhere evading detection even more
intently than the high energy neutrinos
our technology only occasionally
captures
but we do know
they are there
and our only hope lies in a method of
indirect detection
relic neutrinos when they first began
streaming through an otherwise opaque
universe left tiny sonic booms in their
wake small patches of space would become
slightly hotter or slightly cooler with
the small shuffling around of matter and
light as space expanded these patches
would have too therefore a relic
neutrino's influence would be made
apparent within the structure of the
cosmic microwave background and even in
the overall structure of matter in the
universe to this very day
back in 2019 a team of scientists hunted
through the structure and announced the
inferred presence of relic neutrinos yet
not enough to compile an image of the
cnewb other hopes for detection lie in a
special kind of hydrogen atom known as
tritium where the nucleus of a
traditional hydrogen atom is a singular
proton tritium also contains two
neutrons
it is a naturally unstable atom the weak
nuclear force ultimately takes control
converting one of the neutrons into a
proton electron and anti-neutrino but
decay can also be triggered by outside
forces specifically by the collision and
absorption of an incoming neutrino and
it is the energy of that neutrino which
dictates the energy of the escaping
electron the electron which our
technology can measure a relic neutrino
created in the big bang will produce a
different signature than a neutrino
created by another much younger source
with enough tritium our scientists may
be able to build up a vision of the
cosmic neutrino background but the
challenge that lies within such
experiments is the sheer scale required
the catering experiment in germany uses
20 micrograms of tritium and hopes to
detect at most two relic neutrinos in an
entire year
the ptolemy experimented princeton
meanwhile hopes to expand their
prototype detector an atom thick layer
of tritium atop an atom thick layer of
carbon both the size of a postage stamp
up to 100 grams of tritium
their team estimates they might then
capture 10 neutrinos a year
so much effort for so little data
with a picture of the universe at one
second old instead of 380 000 years
scientists will be able to confirm or
contradict decades of mathematical
theory how physics is supposed to work
beyond the sight of our eyes or any of
our current telescopes
the secrets behind that barrier are
simply waiting to be uncovered just like
the cosmic microwave background
permeates all of space the cosmic
neutrino background envelops us
scientists estimate that there are
approximately 300 relic neutrinos and
anti-neutrinos streaming through every
cubic centimeter of space
but not
all of these neutrinos
are the same
over the latter half of the 20th century
scientists discovered that there was
more than one type of neutrino
three flavors were identified and named
after other fundamental subatomic
particles electron muon and tau the
electron neutrino is the most well
studied of the set along with their
antimatter twins they are what's created
when protons or neutrons inside our
everyday atoms interact with the weak
nuclear force they are what's created as
the sun shines
but these are not the only secrets that
neutrinos hold
for they have also found themselves at
the center of controversy
controversy that has shaken the very
bedrock
of physics
[Music]
since 1905 humanity has been taught that
there is a fundamental speed limit to
the universe
einstein's special theory of relativity
dictates that no particle or wave can
traverse space faster than a particular
speed light traversing the vacuum of
space can travel exactly at this speed
limit which we colloquially call the
speed of light
neutrinos once thought to be massless
travel at very nearly the speed of light
but certainly not faster
or can they
in september 2011 a team of physicists
announced that they may have proven
einstein
wrong
the opera collaboration had observed a
beam of neutrinos making the 730
kilometer voyage from cern in geneva
switzerland to the grand sasso national
laboratory near aquila italy and the
beam appeared to travel about 60
billionths of a second faster than the
speed of light in another universe this
result could have been the last
snowflake to fall before an avalanche
the straw that broke relativities back
but dissenting members of the team as
well as other international groups
rushed forth not to confirm their result
but to find where they went wrong where
some kind of error could have been
introduced
after a review scientists identified a
possible culprit a fiber optic cable
which connected the gps technology
tracking the neutrinos journey and the
computer meant to record their arrival
the connection was ever so slightly
loose introducing a bit of lag in the
message from one device to another
another error was identified in the
master clock each tick passing just a
tiny bit too quickly together these
errors could explain the apparent
violation of the rules of nature
subsequent experiments affirmed einstein
and the following march two of the
project's leaders resigned after members
passed a vote of no confidence
neutrinos it turned out did not travel
faster than the speed of light
they did not break that law of physics
but why would anyone think that a
neutrino could break a law of physics
well
they had done it before
the year is 1968.
deep beneath the surface of south dakota
housed within the home stake gold mine
sits a vast shielded neutrino detector
filled with 40 000 liters of
chlorine-based cleaning fluid this
detector's neutrino target is not
man-made as with the earlier project
poltergeist nor intergalactic as with
the later kameoka nde but somewhere in
between
the crushing mass of a star compresses
the hydrogen at its core with such an
intense pressure that temperatures reach
tens of millions of degrees
along with a quirk of quantum mechanics
this heat causes hydrogen nuclei to
engage in a multi-step process which
makes helium
but helium isn't the only byproduct a
continuous stream of photons is released
and a specific flavor of neutrino is
also created
electron neutrinos
by the late 1960s theoretical physicists
had calculated the amount of electron
neutrinos the sun would emit in any
given second as well as how rarely these
neutrinos would interact with matter as
they barrel through the earth
astrophysicists raymond davis jr and
john mccall knew what to expect
but when the count finally came
it was only one-third that estimated
value
davis and mccall had a mystery on their
hands
a mystery that would come to reshape our
understanding of the fundamental
particles that govern our universe
at the time the result was so unexpected
that many believed there had been some
kind of mistake behind it as with the
later opera collaborations results
regarding faster than light travel it
was just a single experiment human error
could have caused the discrepancy or the
estimated number of neutrinos made by
our sun could have been off it was after
all a very complicated calculation a one
percent error in the sun's temperature
would lead to a 30 error in neutrino
count
but as the years passed and experiment
after experiment around the world
continued to replicate davis and bocal's
results it became clear observations
didn't match
theory
the fundamental theory behind the nature
of neutrinos was somehow wrong
but it took nearly 30 years for the
remarkable truth to be found
in 1998 one of camioca nde's successors
super camioca nde completed a study of
atmospheric neutrinos while it was
primarily sensitive to electron
neutrinos researchers had their sights
turned towards its sibling the muon
neutrino created when charged particles
from both the sun and the wider universe
interacted with the earth's atmosphere
but their research uncovered some
quizzical data the number of neutrinos
detected coming from one side of the
planet didn't match the number coming
from the opposite direction given their
ghostly nature the number of neutrinos
detected should not depend on the
direction they're coming from it should
be constant
and it was here that the researchers
suggested a bizarre new idea
something was happening during the muon
neutrino's journey
in between being created in the air and
striking their detectors some had
somehow changed into a third flavor of
neutrino which their detector wasn't
sensitive to
the tau neutrino the slightly longer
distance the earth traversing neutrinos
had to take gave them greater chance to
swap identities and thus go unmeasured
further experiments at the sno in canada
verified the results and it was
conclusive the sun's missing neutrinos
first identified by davis's team had
been found
two-thirds of the electron neutrinos had
turned into
muon or tau neutrinos
at any given moment any one flavor of
neutrino could change into another
and in 2002 davis and koshiba were
awarded the nobel prize in physics for
their initial neutrino detections and in
2015 koshiba's protege and director of
super camioca nde takaki kajita shared
the prize with sno researcher arthur
mcdonald for their discovery of neutrino
oscillation continuing the remarkable
international effort
the principle of neutrino oscillation
had solved the solar neutrino problem
but at the same time threatened to
rewrite the laws of physics
in answering one question they had
opened up
so many others the revelation that
neutrinos could oscillate between one of
three flavors meant that neutrinos had
to have mass but under the standard
model of particle physics neutrinos
should be massless
complicating this further in addition to
three neutrino flavors there are three
neutrino mass states but unfortunately
there is not a one-to-one correspondence
instead of having a scoop of vanilla ice
cream having one mass a scoop of
chocolate having the second mass and a
scoop of strawberry the third each
flavor of neutrino is a neapolitan scoop
with different ratios of vanilla
chocolate and strawberry scientists
aren't even sure what this mass is
experiments using nuclear decay having
narrowed down the mass of the three
states to less than one electron volt
for context the electron itself has a
mass of more than five hundred thousand
electron volts
if neutrinos do have mass they are
dwarfed even by the minnows of the
standard model despite this because of
their sheer number some estimates would
put their total mass as roughly similar
to the mass of all the stars
in the universe
the other major unknown of course is how
neutrinos have mass
at all
the universe in its potentially infinite
size is filled with a variety of
similarly infinite
fields
we are generally familiar with
electromagnetic fields and gravitational
fields but there is one field that
imbues anything that interacts with it
with mass
this
is the higgs field
it is omnipresent invisible and
immutable we only know that it's there
by inferring the detection of its
particle avatar the higgs boson finally
detected to great uproar in 2012.
it is fairly straightforward the more a
given particle interacts with the higgs
field the more mass it gets the most
massive fundamental particle is the top
quark which receives from the higgs a
mass equivalent to what is contained
within a single atom of gold particles
like photons don't interact with the
higgs field at all and stream through
reality with no mass whatsoever
this would suggest that as the least
massive particles known to humankind
neutrinos interact with the higgs field
but just
barely but as we currently understand
neutrinos
this also cannot be true
according to the standard model of
particle physics as particles interact
with the higgs field they not only gain
mass but change a property sometimes
referred to as handedness
swapping from being right-handed to
left-handed and vice versa
thus all matter and antimatter particles
within the standard model come in both
right-handed and left-handed forms
all it seems except for you've guessed
it neutrinos and anti-neutrinos
over all these decades across all our
vast hidden detectors and super powerful
particle accelerators scientists have
yet to observe a right-handed neutrino
or a left-handed anti-neutrino
this means they cannot interact with the
higgs field as science currently
describes they cannot get their mass in
the way all other fundamental subatomic
particles do
what
therefore
is the alternative
given that all neutrinos are left-handed
and anti-neutrinos are right-handed it
may be that neutrinos are actually their
own anti-particle such particles of
which the standard model only counts the
photon and the z naught boson are known
as majorana particles another option is
an addendum to the standard model that
would tie the light neutrinos science
has observed to a heavier counterpart it
so far hasn't
like sitting on a seesaw these much
heavier neutrinos would sit on one side
and lift up the neutrinos on the other
making them lighter or perhaps the
right-handed neutrinos have merely gone
undetected after all this time
right-handed neutrinos may be even more
ghostly than their left-handed twins
interacting exclusively with the higgs
field such right-handed neutrinos may
also be the answer to another neutrino
mystery
sterile neutrinos a flavourless type of
neutrino that would join the ranks of
the electron muon and tau neutrino
flavors if one were ever detected
sterile neutrinos if they do in fact
exist would be even more ghostly than
their flavoured siblings they would not
even interact with the weak nuclear
force only responding to the force of
gravity
the ultimate
ghost particle
if sterile neutrinos are one day
unveiled as a real-world particle like
neutrinos were seven decades ago they
may also contribute to the gravitational
effect astronomers ascribe to dark
matter
and finally it may be that all
right-handed neutrinos existed merely
during our cosmic origin birthed
alongside their siblings in the heat of
creation something in them could have
been unstable and over the 13.8 billion
years time has flowed ever forward they
would have broken down into other
subatomic particles
they would now be lost to us forever any
remnants of them long dispersed
but perhaps
there is a method to see back that far
locked away in ancient structures
like the c
new b
which eventually piece by piece neutrino
by neutrino
humanity will map
neutrinos their elusiveness making them
the ultimate cosmic probe may just help
give us the answers
to their own secrets
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]